negli episodi precedenti di residenti
vol salve dog lo zio tantissimo fra non
sono porto retroporto fantastico ma era
impresa a me lui che evoca le mele
a parte le mail me che crescono però
allora domanda questo interessante ma io
non è che posso va fuori tutte ste cose
con esplosivi ace no 1 è no non ho idea
di dual core a posto
ciao fatto ciao arrivederci non so come
ho fatto uscire è impossibile qualcosa
di lille e non sarà così facile però
vabbè ok sono uscito vanno noi dare lui
cos'è sta roba c'è un tesoro coni che lo
prendo
sono le robe che devi raggiungere molto
difficili da prendere sti tesori al
parco la barca e così se non a chiave va
beh ma minchia la chiave per avviare la
barca per prendere il tesoro o guarda fa
il salto latino scusati no a interagisci
potrebbe rompersi con un po di forza è
parlato ma perché devo fare io
ma io non ho le ba allora io ne lancia
un'altra io l'ultima è mica lo aspetta
nella porzione fortuna pistola ok per
che minchia meno male che non ho usato
la bomba che era l'ultima gavevo perché
poi non posso più passare in cui cosi
come ha fatto a meno che non posso
sparare anche a quelli quindi potrebbe
anche essere così e non lo so non è vera
ma immagino che io lo debba parte dello
zio ci sarà una boxe fight sicuro non
c'è qualcuno li fanno c'è gente minchia
cento mi devo seccare tutti
la donna io mi sono potenziati pure
darmela sono sempre riportali si
potenzia le armi allora questi
potenziano tra di loro quindi non
muoiono mai manca a pagarli proprio
l'arma cielo potenzia tissima è già
figuriamoci il turbo a salvarmi [ __ ] ha
direttamente con la barca e prendere
anche il tesoro questa cosa interessante
offerta che non migliora così esce di
casa lo zio
basta che è palle a via pavia via la
barca senza ci abbia proprio la barca
subito ok
knysna che lo faccio neanche le da fight
ne vado così riderci ok
comunque vedo che secondo me non siamo
fuggiti per niente da questa files ma
zero proprio me lo trovo davanti in 3 2
1 c'è un pescetto simpatico il calcio di
70 di qua mentre il pesce mi mangia vivo
ma non si cura più di proprio thor
captain dopo sei in mezzo alle montagne
per passare sembra sembra accordo con
regalie passi mentre montane con tuo
figlio
ok chissenefrega torchon a ok
sai che c'è di qua ma che ti amano che
posto ai ragazzi ma dove sto da
laboratorio di ricerca vedi che cazzo
succede stanno a fa gli esperimenti
sorridenti incredibile cercarto che
crossover juke al bayern ma e mi
sorprende che tu sia arrivato fino a
chris che bello il re di svezia
era proprio ora certo che sì come no hai
ucciso mia ammazza anche mi ferisce il
lavoro tanto rilievo dei movimenti
preoccupanti polmoni è un passion e non
scusa rivedete accordi sta fuori da
questa storia ma porca vacca la vigata
che lui mentre mi caricava al pesce a
the floor come se visti come se ne
stesse succedendo niente per al tempo di
questa storia penalmente del pesce
arrivava a cui una fortissima quindi
chris non credo sia morto però è stato
divertente
il laboratorio di ricerca c'era una
volta però ancora molto indietro o
cercano di proteggerlo mi sono e questo
lo devo far fuori chi volesse lo faccio
fuori ma è sfruttato come sott'acqua
l'uscita non ho tempo c'è il salvagente
sulla gobba si è visto che culo dovrei
esserci tu che stai parlando
ma che schifo ma che schifo
cazzo di problemi ma cosa sto a guardare
si no beh è stata una cosa
difficilissima
era lui pesce è lui che passava e lui
che basta coco io lo devo batterlo aqua
e lo era lui il passion e in un avvocato
stangona qua bene ottimo io lo devo
battere e saltando la portata per la
forma all'altra
minchia e casino ma adesso che faccio e
che cazzo ne so io mamma mia ragazzi
mamma mia e mi hai fatto che l'uscita è
sott'acqua
guardiola pep guardiola ci ha scritto
qua ok
inserisci amiche dove inserire nov aveva
da che parte lo leggo non capisco non
capisco però va beh devo devo inserire
questori frenati a drenare l'acqua
minchia devo togliere proprio non ce la
corrente pure con la manovella e vecchi
e consumati sembra questa staccati non
si concedessero nel secondo mourinho nel
secondo mulino madonna sta parte ragazzi
un casino non sto cavi niente questo via
condizioni di qualcosa trovarono visto
cose qua e questo lo dirà ok
novemila sto dando ragazzi ecco grazie
ottimo dannazione
devo prendere l'altra il secondo
mourinho che non so dove sia per me
l'aspettavo è sto casino però sono anche
cosa sto facendo
porta la corrente per apportare la
corrente devo riattivare il mulino ok
nel mulino che vorrei c'è soltanto
famiglia di questa cosa sapevano già
però non so come scendere di qua certo
che scendere non so come trovare l'altro
mulino perché non ho capito dove cacchio
arrivò l'anno mi devo fare va bene ci
provo salt per cortesia collabora è non
mi fa cagate che tipo di blocchi perché
se non è difficile
pesci mi sono visto questo di pesci ok
lo sapevo lo sapevo
alpe uno solo è io correre eccolo lì
perfetto sono molto ciao
beh è stato sono morto non succede mai
in realtà i residenti volume è successo
è successo una volta sola prova bene ma
era di fini non ho fatto niente se non
andare avanti quello che è strano ci
siamo ragazzi tobasco l'ho fatto l'ho
fatto
non so come ma lo faccio mai esco
perfetto punto di almeno scoperto qui
c'è almeno qua teoricamente nomi
dovrebbero teoricamente ho detto come
cazzo ci arrivano
devo fare qua un carrello quindi fiji
sono anche questo non solo è sto andando
ma fa niente
lo rivela dall'altro mulino ma in tutto
sto casino è veramente mi piace a
ricaricare la tesla forse ce la faccio a
lapo ce l'ho fatta
l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta quello è volato
papa niente se un po incazzati cosa
faccio gli sparo io non so cosa devo
fare
non gli sparo proprio non ho capito
proprio come faceva sei un [ __ ] non
è quello che hai detto che è sbagliato
ok anche io non scherzo però che cosa
guardatemi madre
sei proprio un bel vedere questa
bellissima donna di dio
con anche dove sta domandando diretto di
qua ce l'ho già passato prima che cazzo
ci sta tornando a fare è sbagliato noi o
giusto
ma no ce n'è un altro adesso porta posto
vai vai minchia
meno male che è volato prima perfetto è
co sti cosi male mi che non si offre di
per forza col fucile ma col fucile va
giù meno male mi chiedo non deve usare
la granata è roba perché sono ancora
tanto strazio perché è un po complicato
in realtà è molto più complicato di
quello che sembra ok
esca grossa oggi brava che battito
naziha complimenti vai a parte
l'olandese volante
se tutto nemico da cui il terzo
e che cazzo è stata giocata
perché mi stava tutto vero ma ha posto
sono altri mulino sono all'altro mulino
ce l'ho fatta ho messo sei anni ma ce
l'ho fatta
porca vacca specie la faccia che non so
come ho fatto ma sono arrivato all'altro
mulino prendi il pezzo che marchio tutto
questo perché mancava una manovella
ceduto sto perdendo per una manovella mi
sembra mi sembra tutto giusto
oppure
prima che crolli il mulino prendi
bravissimo prima che crolli il mulino io
non andrei proprio via col non puoi a
raffica chiusi non so neanche dove sto
andando
ora prendi la minchia la scala mobile no
bellissimo mascara si è creata questo
gene torino bellissimo
il tesoro c'è quello che abbiamo
no guarda minchia non l'ho visto
be nice
meno male che non è ancora in 3d sto
gioco che sono poi sarebbe stato un
problema però a posto ho fatto altro
punto un po tom cruise in tutto questo
quindi bene benissimo
tutto è bene quel che finisce non
impasto a godzilla da questo casino per
fare questa cosa ragazzo incredibile
ok ok un cazzo a chi lo stai dicendo tra
l'altro allora vai hanno già andato
perfetto
cosa devo fare dove tra questi colori
qua c'è un arancione ok qua c'è un
bianco perfetto qua c'è un azzurro
bianco arancione perfetto perfetto
rifatto drena tutta l'acqua
vai come il lavandino bravo lo scarico
attirato mette anche un po di mastro
lindo perché secondo me volevo non
faccia e dallo scarto sta morendo
speriamo allora che no no no no no no no
hanno saltato sono andato ok che kakà
mento di palle questo i quali possono
passare bellissimo ma quella fare non
torna più vero non li devo anche sparare
addosso spero
purtroppo da zico picchia
affronta a che quale veramente potevo
sparare anche prima allora no ma dai
veramente prova a far cuore
acer barile esclusivo meno male
quando arriva lo faccio saltare gas
avere un po di foto un altro
teoricamente nuovo fratello puoi farla
come vuoi
passi che ti fai salta in aria se questo
è questo e profumi che non capisco in
giro che fa va fuori giri strani
lo zio no
basta posto
cosa vogliamo fare con la piccolina ma
trovate ascoltami che staimo vita mi
faccio l'amore nella ascoltami parti c'è
da dire di nuovi chiamata usato tre cosi
ragazzi che sono sempre debole ma
veramente fortissimo mi ha fatto
affidare a lui che tutti gli altri
nostri siti
la donna che e male tra vuole votare di
coltellino e morto l'ho capito
non è molto procede lily capitolo di saw
vi capito tutti i proiettili
mi sa che c'è un l'implosione insorto
city bello adesso fantastico abbiamo tre
pezzi di quattro manca solo quello che
sta alla fabbrica no che si chiama a sé
cosa heisenberg vi ricordo che sia mai
sembra che va beh come fai dimenticatevi
uno di schiava heisenberg impossibile
chiave costretto come con i segnali qua
minchia pure the ring gli stava
guardando pure la televisione lo zio
mondo l'ho vista eccola qua dobbiamo
collegarci l'altra chiave ok perfetto e
adesso si rispetto con 6 ali6 meglio di
ciò che pensiamo
grazie chi paga è questo vantiamo
siamo la stessa persona ieri da c'è una
fortezza e appena fuori dal villaggio fi
e prendi il mio flacone se lo fai avrà i
finti mi puzza un po che i mafiosi ma
proprio giusto un po ok allora abbiamo
sto coso e fatemi uscire subito subito
subito subito due che era uscita qua a
destra
adesso no questo e l'ascensore
eccola la i quali qua ragazzi allora
esco a destra ma qua dentro che cosa qua
l'arma nascosta di moroto come cazzo
centro in questo posto a manovella
non lo so
la manovella sarebbe utile è qua in
questo la manovella manovella amica ok
perfetto giornata ea questo lo devo fare
incredibile regolatevi io non devo fare
altro per favore
poi prende regolarmente la voglio non so
cosa sia ma la voglia ci stiamo
arrivando e ragazze qua guarda vado
dritto ma solo perché voglio vedere che
cos'è non me ne sbatto di kimi stata che
non sono anche chi sia
[Applauso]
c'è un pozzo non è vero che dentro c'era
la gente che ha visto giusto che siano
bastati a fare è che pastiglie insieme a
7 miliardi chiede adesso vogliono con
meno forza invece da dire questo poco è
stato io di precisione il solito nice
ce l'ho fatta perfetto così trovato
forno fatto in tempo a vedere comprese
basta va bene c'è ancora qualcuno qui
invece rivista a casa posso eccola qua
dimmi che si apre per favore è chiusa
dall altro la di fragole di legno secca
la sento qualcuno dentro tra l'altro la
finestra aperta frequenza cioccolato fa
bene restare ma segreta lo zio totò di
chi
[Applauso]
mori che la madonna
cos'è star ma fammi vedere minchia è una
piccola tavolo bellissimo è una ma è una
revolver loreto reti di magnum aspetta
quindi non c'è io io prete il mai domo
celio
non ce li ho ce li ho chiedevo che
picchia e come loro uso è abbastanza per
farsi per di mangiarlo la diavel a
tecnico fa niente
minchia bellissimo bellissimo ragazzo o
questa questa è una bella questa è una
bella perché la retina di quanto è forte
la la magnum i residenti allora mi sa
che sblocco st porta ma c'è stata ma
dietro
vediamo non è vero mai me ne va dopo a
me ne vado ragazzi cia per cortesia non
ne faccio fuori un altro minchia che
palle
no non ne faccio fuori un altro si corri
corri sbattitene mentre in casa vedi 16
aprile niente
lo zio qua 2t non mi ha preso come un
nome no ragazzi spesso male non ha fatto
non colpirmi sporca [ __ ]
chi aveva visto questo pezzo se bloccato
lì che curò il catanese che culo assurdo
via via via via via via via forma letale
no non lo so non lo so paolo via fuori
dalle palme non voglio l'inter è più
attenti e stato bello arrivederci meno
male che c'è lo zio a indicarmi la
strada perché sono cugat
allora abbiamo la porta mistica da
aprire con la nuova chiave effettua
segnali madonna good luck grazie a zitto
mi chiamano mesi almeno è simpatico da
che parte vado vado di qui il sito wwf
più allegra è alzato qualcosa allora
l'ho vivi appesi però che se vivi per
modo di dire giorno
voi non vi muovete per favore voi siete
gli unici che cavalcano che schifo è
questo qua elena più e più artista
presente e allora sono morto morto
quanta gente c'è porca vaghe 2 milioni
d'incanto timori ce ne sono 65 mm vabbè
veniva scoperto ha deciso a lui ha detto
vabbè tanto ti porto lui si conferma la
tenuta e vinci da no sono caduto giù
tutti a spylo non ne va bene una donna
che male
ok ok ok non è proprio ok ma tra un
successo e quello con l'arco ce n'è uno
con l'arco che ma spara dall'art e
mancato un compenso di sta colpendo
proprio minchia quello con l'arco e
tosto è porca [ __ ] lo colpì subito la
freccia non ci credo io colpito la
precede gli è rimbalzata indietro e morì
quanto tempo è morto madonna con l'altra
tosto è fighissimo
c'è anche un corso per far esplodere qua
qua ci deve essere un boss mezzo ba qua
c'è un altro licantropo di quelli grossi
ve lo dico io ma a parte il fatto
ragazzi che poi c'è un tesoro della
fortezza che sta proprio qua c'è
esattamente qua sopra teoricamente me lo
vede
giovanni m va bene
corri corri bravo quanta gente ancora
devo ammazzare qui dichiara che pietro
grazie vuoi pinocchio quanti cazzo siete
o ragazzino infatti già fuori 2000 come
cazzo
allora e non c'è più colpi ottimo
dell'amira travail va bene forse sarebbe
stato meglio usa adesso ti faccio fuori
come un proiettile sono di pompa afghana
ok
stavo dicendo gli faccio fare completi e
solo repo meno male
e comunque non li ho usati i vari di
esplosivi forse era meglio usarli a sto
punto
meno male o troppo benedizione la
pistola perché stavo messo da cani non
ce l'ho proprio più proiettili allora
qua mi dice tesoro e la fortezza io non
lo vedo meno che non sia qua sopra
ma io posso arrampicarmi là sopra vedo
che ci sono potresti arrampicarti
volendo e ma non lo fai
ora mentre faccio st cagata fucile
precisione si certo
mentre tenta di aprire sta roba ma
quanto quanto ci fate che arriva a
satana a farmi fuori proprio cioè chiaro
guarda guarda guarda ma anzi esce da lì
proprio no non è uscito di eccolo lo zio
è ancora pieno di barili grazie io
rimarrei qui sopra perché
stare questo fu ucciso almeno dovrei
averlo almeno colpito spero aiuto min
chiamate perché peggio mi sento fate o
questi sono olimpionici schiatta scarti
arrugginiti ottimo la tesi quanta gente
e vabbè non potevo deviarli tutti era
impossibile ok non male ce n'è uno qua
nice
very nice porca [ __ ] non mai
vabbè non fatti fuori 2000 e ne arrivano
altri 2000 questa cosa è interessante
style inizio no mago noti serio aspetto
che devo fare il giro strano come arrivo
dall altra parte
minchia è il prezzo di uno gigi sopra
non ho visto c'è la scala buono infatti
fuori training colpo raga non male not
bad giro mentre tiro possono colpirmi
chi prende soldi non ti possono colpire
ma non so se proprio dai soci ed amici
darmi un po di colpi ma proprio pochi
anche grazie a zio
meno male che mi paghi ok ok però uno o
che un altro 2 giovane poi mai stati
nome statino poi statino la nazione
amica alla vecchia maria in maniera che
è una figata sentire gente che ruggisce
non capire da dove arriva subito però
ecco se salti se riuscissi a saltare lì
ma da questo tesoro più avanti tipo la
porca vacca di riuscire a saltare la in
qualche modo zio è che non è difficile
che non c'è il tasto di salto sul
residenti voler per quello il problema
vabbè vediamo di andare avanti a me
almeno arrivare dal tizio ma non stava
in una fabbrica colori fortezza e mi
ricordavo che mi ricorda voce che fosse
una fabbrica di mezzo perché aveva detto
che lavorava in una fabbrica o lo la ma
questa non è una fabbrica proprio tutto
l'opposto
a meno che non mi ci abbia mandato solo
per il flacone ma è la tua vita in un
altro posto proprio salvataggio ok
vediamo laga dove mi porta stoppa in più
difficile da capire perché
effettivamente non ho idea questo è
tutto ragazzi meno che è una fabbrica
proprio non c'entra niente di non ci
vado io ricordo bello allegro queste
tutte abitazioni di dark souls è in
realtà quasi scatena l'inferno io ne
traggono proprio è infatti a parte il
bari l'esplosivo che già sto vedendo
[Musica]
aspetto non me l'aspettavo per niente
due tizi dovrei averli seccati ok minuto
porca vacca c'è uno di qui nicchia non
me l'aspettavo mai mai proprio fucile a
pompa boys tu ti togli tanto qua dietro
non c'è nessuno
123 madonna e casinò
ecco qua la velocità di ricarica non
sarebbe male che non me la metto mai io
nel fucile
quando sarebbe stata male perché ci sono
talmente tanti versi chissenefrega
ma chi se ne frega proprio jolo
va beh ti ho sprecato sprecato usato
62.000 colpi però però poteva anche
andar peggio forse non dovrei parlare
verso devo periodo può stare zitto
stare zitto porca [ __ ] corri non so
dove stiamo andando
lo so ok va bene non so se fate gente
che salta la spider man non so neanche
dove sto andando lega sto correndo senza
meta datemi un barile esclusivo per
cortesia 1 un bar in un bar in esclusivo
per fare uno solo merda merda che ogni
pressione luce un bestione ok è stato
quello devo portare sul bari che sposino
sicuro che vorrei fare il giro al
contrario ragazzi devo fare c'è un tizio
grosso che devo fare esplodere col bari
l'esplosivo per forza allora l'ho visto
18 st 18 per ed esplosivo
se io rimango nei paraggi a spettatori
di quello grosso teoricamente potrei
anche fare questo tipo un'arena e
ragazzi con il 6
ok minchia quanti sono lo zio vieni qua
per favore che essere un casino yes
proprio qui non ce n'erano due hanno
questo qua non c'è questo non normale
che non si è fatto niente
[ __ ] bar agosto fuggire che cazzo
celaya fa che è ancora vivo quel certo
mi ha colpito in uno grosso però prima
di far fuori quello devo far bene questo
qua se non me ne vado riguardanti ok c'è
troppa gente ragas che sono veramente un
miliardo ok
ho troppa gente dietro davanti un
macello non si può non ci si può muovere
proprio ok userei lanciagranate per
questo ma solo sprecherei perché poi si
usa per i posti letto
ok ma magari da cecchino forse tutta la
scienza la sua volta è morto dai ho
beccato in testa pensava [ __ ] che
male
c'è anche la magnum raga ciò anche la
newco che non solo sta usando al meglio
non ti fare un cazzo mi raccomando eh se
ti sparo come sono gli stessi facendo
niente
ok ho fatto mezzo disastro ma li ho
fatti fuori tutti va bene ho sprecato un
miliardo di cure ma dovrebbe essere a
posto allora torniamo dove eravamo
rimasti che non mi ricordo neanche dove
dove era spuntato indizio se c'era
qualcosa non fatti fuori un miliardo
ragazzi veramente basta basta gente
sentito scricchiolare qualcosa ne ho
fatti fuori un milione speriamo almeno
che ne sia valsa la pena vediamo qua non
c'è niente ok sono sta portando teva
aprire l'anteprima teoricamente u per
natura salve a lei ho bisogno di capire
dove stiamo andando di sotto porca vacca
tutto sto casino per trovare l'ultimo
pezzo del puzzle di mia figlia
diciamo che è stata una giornata piena e
meno che capiamo che è successo in
questo modo jackets c'è stata capretta
aspetta
sento gente sento gente anche c'è
continua c'è sempre adesso mi sbuca dal
muro tipo michela dentro un posto che
non conosco dal muro ritengo
ecco cosa dice minchia acquista e la
sala mensa la caffetteria
meno male
quello è un kebab che gira orca vacca
dalle perché non mi vedono già non
riguarda né ho usati un miliardo ricordi
per favore ve lo chiedo per cortesia ma
ecco che c'è un punto di salvati grazie
avermi messo un punto di salvataggio che
almeno so che se devo morino faccio con
onore ma come metto piede sotto sono
finito sono un uomo morto defunto ecco
io entrare qua dentro e male
si mette male perché chi c'è
mi piace 1 grado di
no lui no quindi ragazzi questa era la
fine l'episodio di presidenti non lo so
che conosciuto sempre questi episodi i
modi incredibili però scivola sass muss
penso che la sedia cento la spesa è
bella la dovete sentire anche voi e
quindi ci vediamo al prossimo video ip
da ragazzi
[Musica]